consider the system y is equal to 2x
plus 3.75 and 5x minus 2y is equal to
negative nine point five determine how
many solutions the system has and then
classify the system as consistent or
inconsistent and the equations is
dependent or independent so let's just
review a little bit what all of these
words mean so let me draw the different
scenarios we can have when we have two
equations with two unknowns or we have
two lines in two dimensions so let me
I'll draw them up here actually if I'm
really relatively small so that's my
y-axis that is my x-axis so it's Y and X
let me copy and paste this a couple of
times so let me copy and paste it that's
one scenario that's another scenario and
then let me paste the third scenario and
let me draw out the scenarios all I've
done so far is I've drawn the axes so I
could have one scenario where I have two
lines in the two-dimensional coordinate
plane and there are two different lines
and they intersect in exactly one point
so that could be one point that could be
one line that could be the other line
then I could have two lines that are two
separate lines but they never intersect
and they never intersect because they
have the exact same slope but different
y-intercepts the different y-intercepts
is what allows them to have different to
be different lines different but
parallel lines and then these obviously
will never if the if a system that of
these two equations or these two lines
will never intersect because two
parallel lines never intersect and then
finally you could have a scenario where
you where both both equations are
essentially describing the exact same
line now depending on whether you look
at the equations or the system itself
there's different ways to label these
things so if you look at the equations
themselves so from an equations point of
view these two equations are clearly to
two separate lines they are not the same
lines here so we call these two
equations as being independent these two
the equations that these lines represent
are off these two lines
also two separate lines they are not the
same line so once again we say the
equations that these lines represent are
once again independent independent here
the two equations represent the exact
same lines so here we're talking about a
dependent D about dependent equations so
these are independent equations
independent equations dependent
equations now it becomes slightly
different or we use slightly different
words when we think about the system and
when you think about the system you care
more about the number of solutions that
you might have so here when you have
exactly one solution this is consistent
and a consistent system has at least one
solution consistent so this clearly has
one solution this has an infinite number
of solution any point here will be a
solution so this is also consistent
consistent has at least one solution and
this right over here these are two
different lines that never intersect it
has no solution no common point for both
of these lines so this is inconsistent
inconsistent so over here a system that
describes lines like this would be
consistent a system that describe lines
that are essentially the same line would
be inconsistent sorry a system that
describes lines that are essentially the
same lines would be consistent because
here you have an infinite solution
infinite number of solutions here you
have one solution here this system is
inconsistent because it has no solutions
we look at the equations these equations
the equations that are represented by
these lines are independent the
equations that are represented but these
lines are independent the equations that
are represented by these lines are
dependent because they're essentially
the same line
now that out of the way let's actually
talk about this problem determine how
many solutions the system has and then
classify so the one way to think about
it this top equation this top equation
is already in slope-intercept form we
know its slope and its y-intercept is
3.75 we can essentially put the second
equation into slope-intercept form and
see how its slope and y-intercept
compare and if it has it well if it has
well let's compare it and then we'll
think about which of these three
scenarios it falls under
so let me write 5x minus 2y
is equal to negative nine point five I
want to isolate a y on the left hand
side so let's subtract 5x from both
sides and so my left-hand side becomes
negative 2y my right-hand side is
negative 5x minus nine point five now I
can divide both sides by negative two by
negative two to divide all the terms by
negative two and I get Y is equal to
negative five divided by negative 2 is
positive two point five x and then four
nine point five divided by two is four
point seven five the negatives cancel
out so plus four point seven five so I
just rewrote I just rewrote the second
equation in slope intercept form its
slope is different than the first
equation this first equation has a slope
of two this one is two point five and
it's y-intercepts are different but the
slopes being different that by itself is
enough to know that these are going to
be two separate lines that are not
parallel if the slopes were the same
then we're say okay we're either dealing
with parallel lines or the same line but
since the slopes are different we know
that we're doing dealing with two
different lines that are not parallel so
we're definitely dealing with this
scenario right over here so these
equations are independent and this
system when we look at both of them
together this system right over here is
going to be consistent we will have we
will have exactly one solution so this
when we know since they have different
slopes we're dealing with this scenario
we are going to have one solution which
makes it consistent being if someone
told you that a system was consistent
that by itself isn't enough to say that
it has exactly one solution consistent
tells you it's at least one solution
you'd be dealing with this scenario or
this scenario the reason why we know it
has one solution is that the slopes are
different two point five versus two the
slopes are different so we know we're
dealing with this scenario right here
two non parallel lines that are not the
same lines and they will intersect in
exactly one place and have exactly one
solution I should
- that right over there